Oh long week long week hey what's going
on guys lives are very interesting and
tiring a week it's been busy as usual
but uh you know as most relationships go
Maryland I come to a little bit of an
argument it's natural in a relationship
here's my opinion if you don't fight
with your spouse you're [ __ ] stupid
either that or you don't love them
enough to sock him in the stomach that's
true love when we spend quality time I
tend to get distracted because I have so
many things on my mind so we were having
lunch and I was kind of just you know
dozing off so when we spent quality time
which we don't get to do a lot of it I'm
kind of doing that [ __ ] she is really
pissed off but you should see the way
she reacted you were on a different
level of anger like right off the bat
your face look like a kabuki warrior man
but of course in every relationship
after you fight you have to make up and
what better way to do it than to go to
decently laughs what's the difference
between California ventures in a
Disneyland drink
I see I never really liked Disneyland an
another sounds [ __ ] crazy but
Disneyland is expensive as [ __ ] you know
funny enough I actually got an annual
pass first because I know that she loves
Disney she loves Disneyland and so we
would make use of it turns out the
[ __ ] girl decides to go ahead and get
a job at Disney so the my annual pass
went out the window here we are at
Disneyland 60th anniversary we are going
to have a fantastic time remember my
dear hold it steady
that's right Meryl and I haven't been to
Disneyland in a while because we've been
so busy she actually works for Disney
and uh I got a with all season pass yes
annual pass and we haven't been able to
utilize itself we decide to come out on
a Sunday and have a good time and uh you
know you coupley stuff oh my god every
now and then I'll see like a couple of
my girlfriends like they just go with a
group of dude and I'm like dude that's
[ __ ] weird
the only reason any male above the age
of 18 should be at Disneyland is one if
he's with this girl number two
and he's trying to pick up babies you
[ __ ] perverts if you are 40 years old
and you're still going to digital and
buy yourself think about it you look
like a baby toucher I think it was a
good way for me to make up for the
things that I did but interestingly
enough even though I do [ __ ] up every
now and then I still stop with the jokes
yep thought I was single this whole
tonight single matters news
and it turns out in our relationship
most of times when I make jokes she
doesn't laugh and I'm the only person to
find it funny my god it's Cinderella I
don't like white girls but hmm
a little interesting thing about Muriel
she [ __ ] loves frozen when we first
started going out I told her that I
wasn't too hyped about the frozen movie
like you were excited more than the
little children were that was the
creepiest part this relax did relax
you
I think they're just like taking it back
oh my god is she from
also like I do
throughout the day I was trying to teach
her how to vlog cuz I think she not that
she ever wants to open up her own
YouTube channel that's not at all what
she's doing but she was gonna grab the
GoPro stick and go about and talk I kind
of wanted her to emote a little bit
talking to the camera hello everybody
like it no you're not loud enough you're
holding back your voice why are you
doing that everybody even you have to
think about it like this who cares what
people think it doesn't really matter at
that point yeah oh by celica Jack yes go
ahead
today what we're gonna do is be really
quiet cuz I'm shy to talk to myself in
public I talk to myself in public for a
living Chari yah Tom if you dance on a
pole yes that makes you a ho yeah of
course when it comes to like
relationships stuff I like doing stuff
outside of the house and going out and
having fun because you know when you
when you always stay inside of a room
and that's kind of like your guys's
comfort zone an area you don't really
get to know that person that well to be
honest with you wasn't good
go ahead
I know some of you out there are
perfectly fine being couch potatoes and
that's okay too and so am i I love
staying at home because I travel so much
but when you guys do things together you
guys also create memories together you
do have like particular experiences that
you get to talk about that you did on
your own but now it's time for you guys
to create memories for yourself and this
is why I prefer doing things outside
with it cuz I don't get to spend a lot
of time of it so what I do I definitely
try to make your channel yeah plus when
we go out and do things we're quirky
side comes out a little she's a little
weird
Oh
because for me it's all about creating
memories you know so that when you look
back at what you guys done and what you
guys did together and created it's not
just staying in one place those those
memories are important because even for
me right now you know I've been taking a
lot of pictures of us and that's
something I used to hate doing I used to
hate taking pictures of myself I
technically didn't even like being in
front of camera but I do it now because
she kind of mentioned something where I
think so many photos of her she realized
that I was never in the photos and if
it's our memories then where am i you
know I should be a part of it as well
one two three
how's that
- for yo-yo style yo beauty Oh smiles
got me feeling some type of way makes me
lift my hands and praise be sighs your
body's bona fide won't you sit better
than Sunday best